per i ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono palio ci siamo dati non è vero non
ho mai fatto questa roba comunque sia
cubi che non c'entra niente con il cubo
di rubik o robe del genere però vi
spiego allora hanno fatto una specie di
mix tra amata
questo il menu ma posso già muovermi
bellissimo hanno fatto ragazzo in mix
tra the impossible game o geometri darci
quello che volete e super meat boy
niente io sono sto cubo che deve fare le
cose devo arrivare al traguardo
fin qui niente di strano c'è il
contatore delle morti e ragazzi quindi
immagino sia la roba abbastanza
difficile però per adesso niente di
strano prova ad andare dritto verso il
finale bel good niente male ragazzo che
mi sta stupendo di me stessa io come
faccio meglio a stare zitto old jam
poker dream works tic ok a bellissimo
posso attaccarmi ai muri bellissima sta
roba
porca vacca immagino che da ora inizia a
diventare un po più incasinato prove
l'altro ragazzi non so se ve ne siete
accorti però doveva uscire super meat
boy forever questa primavera ad aprile
doveva uscire ad aprile siamo a dicembre
come è possibile mi ricordo ragazzi che
giocavo a quello con l'uomo a toni ed
porca vacca porca a ieri tools home è
più o meno nella stessa roba non giocare
a nove le genera quando giocato quello
del luogo però correre
ok ma diventando sempre più difficile
ragazzi cè un casino così aiuto 2 vado
cosa devo fare qui a devo salire ok si
sta in trippando giusto un attimo il
cervello ok ma cosa devo fare
ma non si può fare è qualcuno glielo
spieghi
no ragazzi non si può fare st barth e
scusatemi scherzavo si può fare bei
ragazzi allora non me la sto cavando
male
un altro gioco è veramente figo parties
che sono io che sono un po scarso non
fate quello aiuto aiuto aiuto help vado
sono stato bravissimo
e vabbè lo dovrei fare con il signor
gatto questo gioco vedete come prende
piede e bene allora perfetto il cubo
cosa mi serve succube scusatemi dovuto
portare dietro
no non avevo portatile parco demonio
venire sono morto sapevo come di fare le
cagate dai una guarda ok a sinistra
bravo bravo
non vorrei fare troppe morti perché poi
me ne contano prova per chi se ne frega
tanto non stiamo poi a fare il record
del mondo
porca vacca comunque ragazzi voi sapete
che quando ci sono dei cupi in un gioco
ci sono dei triangolini da evitare il
gioco di fa bestemmiare è così che
funziona tutti ragazzi ogni volta che
comando un quadrato ciò dei problemi e
allora 10b lei scherzavo del franchi in
fretta ma ci manca solo quello ho speso
5 euro fammi vedere che gli vale sti
soldi ma non ce la fanno vincere ne
spendo altri cinque anni fa vincere
ok ok veri punto ragazzi mamma mia mamma
mia
allora se arrivava 20.000 lycra del
prossimo video diventa un cubo e vado a
uccidermi non scherza madonna si vedono
triste lami in giro
porca vacca mai mi hai preso per un emo
basta co ste lame tutt'altra roba
basta magagna guarda o schiacciati tasti
mille volte guarda 1040 limite se è
normale non roba del genere madonna se
no io non so più come fare quello giuro
meno male non sono molto ma non so non
avrei mai più saputo di fare quella roba
ecco ma io lo so che ci sono i malati
che sul tuo gioco
il cielo finiscono tutti in una botta
sola heroes ora lo so mi sa che lo
diciate lo so
maledizione o a vista che devo correre
ma la chiara metà basta proprio perfetto
aiuto cosa devo fare
genova aspetta cielo per non ce la farò
mai però cielo lo sapevo io sapevo che
non ci avrei mai fatto ma ciò dovuto
provare ragazza era giusto comunque che
non ne vedo altri modi sono a questo
madonna ma io posso saltare più volte no
va bene a posto non fatemi domande
ragazze tutto ok è tutto ok tutto a
posto tutto funziona benissimo nella mia
vita non c'è niente che non va ok
perfetto
la gara veramente sta andando avanti il
sacco quant'è che dura
la strada facile non è mai la strada
giusta ragazzi sto livello infattibile
non lo so se ve ne siete accorti
lo dico io porca vacca
ok ora devo devo salutare noi
impossibile ok
ma cos'ha fatto vado a su cifre un
miliardo di volte non ci riesco futuro
vado aspettare che la mascherata ok no
era più veloce quella sotto io sono
stupito molto bene a posto equa ma non
posso farmi leggere molto bene molto
bene donna guarda l'ho fatto l'ho fatto
l'ho fatto portico si sbaglia cosa c'è
nella mia vita che non funziona spiega
mi tra l'altro ragazzi ho tirato un
pugno alla tastiera è un miracolo che
non mi sia non mi si sia fermata la
registrazione che si ferma senza motivo
in realtà però la legge dice che si deve
fermare la registrazione sentire un pò
di una tastiera strano che non sia
successo e comunque ragazzi sta tastiera
sopravvive da mille pugni quindi
complimenti alla razer stiamo esagerando
qual è allora decidi tu no ragazzi qua
sta dietro gelatissimo
ho capito ma ma come faccio come ma non
pazzo da ragazzi c'è qualcosa che non va
come faccio
madonna ragano vi giuro su livelli
inguardabile ma finirà prima o poi sto
gioco deve continuare ancora per molto
ce l'avevo fatta però ci ha messo una
vita però siamo fatta no basta fermo che
ti distruggo infiniti genitali non ce li
hai sei un cubo cioè io i genitali
quadrati adesso allora io teoricamente
dovrei passare oltre
madonna fesso veramente vale in questo
momento 37 anni ciò
avevo anche fatto il test no
basta basta ma qualcuno ragazzi l'ha mai
superato suo livello
no perché veramente impossibile basta
basta non ce la faccio più non ne posso
più
otto ore 2124 tasti premuti va bene
madonna ragazzi ma guarda se questo poi
è più facile mi incazzo quel livello era
invisibile invincibile l'indecoroso in
the corribile 1 ragazzi inguardabile
veramente non so veramente cosa dire ho
buttato la mia vita in quel momento lei
ok no no no no no no ok io no no no se
hanno rotto le palle
basta ancora no ma non posso passare
sopra il triangolino no ragazzi qualcuno
può farmi fermare qua vi prego madonna
però dato avantissimo
vorrei fermarmi quadri questo desiderio
è possibile vediamo vediamo la gente
quanto ha fatto per curiosità quindi
nessuno ha fatto questo gioco
l'ho fatto solo io sapete perché perché
sono stupido signori spero che questo io
vi sia piaciuto è stato molto rilassante
a me piacciono i video rilassanti perché
in qualche modo mi aiutano ad affrontare
poi la giornata e questo è uno di quelli
previsti invece due ragazzi quasi un bel
commento mi piace ai scrivete a creare
che una cosa molto importante la capa
nellina dove schiacciare perché mi aiuta
tanto e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]